Blue has always been a sort of problem
fluorescent way because they're not a
great many natural materials that are
available that are blue in color and
serve as pigments there is a very fine
and precious blue which is available
from the semi precious stone core that
is lazuli the yields of pigment called
the ultramarine a particularly striking
examples used natural ultramarine can be
seen in this picture by Saturday at Oh
who was a Roman school painter in the
17th century and it shows the Virgin in
prayer and her blue drapery is painted
the most fantastic quality at wash
marina really shows you the quality this
wonderful pigment before the 19th
century there was only one known source
of lapis lazuli in the world nits in
place it's called Badakhshan which is in
what's now North East Afghanistan and
there were some famous mines there at
playschool saw assange and all the lapis
lazuli that was used across the world
from ancient times came from that one
single source it was the only place that
it occurred
you can't just take lapis-lazuli however
good the quality of the color and just
grind it up and mix it with a paint
medium to make a very satisfactory
pigment you actually have to extract the
pigment from the mixture of minerals
that constitute lapis lazuli and the
discovery of that process of extraction
came into being in the 12th century in
Europe what they did was that they used
wax and mastic and pine tert turpentine
and ground it together and then washed
it with lye and then you ended up with
grades of the of the letter of the
leisure right which is the blue portion
of the of the stone and so that is one
of the highest quality examples and as
extraction process went on the quality
would go down and to admit to a mid blue
and then finally to what is called the
ultramarine ash which is a much lower
grade blue there were alternatives
ultramarine the most important one for
early pictures is another mineral
pigment called azure-eyed
azurite occurs in quite a number of
european locations particularly in
southern France in Germany and in
Hungary and it was used in egg tempera
and reducing oil so it was really quite
an important the to the great
disadvantage of azurite in comparison
with ultramarine is that it doesn't have
the wonderful pure blue color quality
that ultramarine has and particularly
when you mix it with a paint medium it
often becomes quite greenish in tone and
that's not a very desirable
characteristic in a pigment there was a
very interesting discovery at the
beginning of the 18th century when an
alchemist who was called Dipel who was a
swiss code maker working berlin
discovered quite by chance a new blue
pigment called Prussian blue and it was
a chance discovery he was in fact trying
to make a red pigment and some of the
materials he was using to manufacture
that red pigment were contaminated and
he ended up instead of with this red
pigment this blue pigment which is a
compound called ferric ferrocyanide so
you wouldn't be able to make that sort
of material intentionally it was a
completely charged discovery but its
importance was that this was really the
first synthetic pigment in a modern
sense and it came to be manufactured in
quite large quantities as not as pigment
so it really started the chemical
revolution in creating new pigments for
artists to use before the early 19th
century there were no methods of
chemical analysis in existence that were
able to show the correct chemical
composition of something so complex as
natural ultramarine but at that time
particularly what was called
quantitative chemical analysis began to
appear and the work of two French
chemists enabled natural ultramarine to
be
analyzed and that really led to the
discovery of the the artificial form of
the pigment well it took a very long
time for them to find out the true
nature of just of ultramarine it's a
complex sulfur containing sodium and
aluminium silicate and and it wasn't
until 1806 that they managed to actually
find out exactly what the structure was
and then it was another 20 years before
they managed to produce what is these
decent they synthetic type of
ultramarine which is the very very
intense blue so that was finally done
in 1826 and after that time very quickly
they actually developed large quantities
both in France and in Germany French
ultramarine was fantastic commercial
discovery it was published as a method
of manufacture in 1828 and so successful
is that by the 1830s there already
factory set up to manufacture synthetic
ultramarine in large quantities and it
became a very important pigment not just
for painting but for all kinds of
colouring purposes we have in the
National Gallery collection a very large
picture by George Sura called the
bathers and Sarah made a number of small
sketches as preliminary design to this
picture and one of the pigments use very
widely both in the series of sketches
and in the main picture itself was
French Agra Marie so he was a sort of
fan of this pink one
you